martine michel saint et christian dufour
sont avec nous bonsoir je le disais une
interpellation lors de l'étude des
crédits c'est un peu une entrevue menée
par les chefs de l'opposition envers
dans ce cas ci le premier ministre dont
qui peut avoir des surprises
première surprise crise du logement
manon massé qui a attaqué entre
guillemets sur ce sujet là je vous fais
entendre ceux qui n'étaient pas avec
nous en début d'émission les changes qui
prête et ona qui a eu lieu donc un peu
plus tôt à québec ça coûte combien
logement à montréal
bah écoutez ça dépend de la grandeur du
logement mais je dirais ça peut
peut-être commencé à 5 600 dollars par
mois assez rapidement monté à 1000
dollars par mois
et monsieur le président sachez que les
étudiants pour en avoir eu chez moi
quand j'étais à sainte anne de bellevue
parfois vont se mettre trois quatre
ensembles pour louer logement s'organise
avec les moyens du bord ça fait des mois
contact humain 7,2 pour vous parle de
crise de logement et le point on va
capoter cas les tentes vont pousser d'un
seul bord des autoroutes des prochains
mois c'est déjà commencé tout le mot
crise est fort il manque de logements on
est en train d'en construire qu'ils mais
je ne suis pas déconnecter alors tour de
table je ne suis pas déconnecter plein
monsieur lebon martin biron pour 500
dollars le germe montréal oubliez ça ça
n'existe pas on a fait des milliers de
reportages la presse en avait un la fin
de semaine dernière presque des taudis
pour neuf chats qu'en pensez vous il
n'ya pas passé le test de la peine de
lèvres c'est un test fréquemment qu'on
entend des journalistes qui pour
succéder question là c'est pas vraiment
dans les cartons du gouvernement la
question de la crise du logement et le
gouvernement est questionné la tuent
régulièrement presque tous les jours à
la période de questions et il martèle
pour la même réponse c'est à dire on a
on avait 15 mille logements à construire
que les libéraux nous ont laissés ils
ont pas vraiment de grands projets ils
sont pas vraiment interpellé par ce
dossier là c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui la
lumière était passablement baraqué sur
la situation je suis le goût dit que le
taux d'inoccupation avait avait
légèrement augmenté la de 1.9 à douze
ennemis mais probablement que ça va
sonner une cloche
ok michel c'est qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé souvenez vous quand monsieur
couillard avait dit pendant la campagne
électorale à une famille de 4 pourrait
sauver pour 60 les espèces par semaine
ça c'est son 75 espèces par semaine
si moi déconnectée jeunes ce qu'il est
parce que l on peut pas je trouvais rien
à 500 $ pour une chambre
si tant est que les maisons de chambres
sont pas soit libre au québec à montréal
et tout le monde les dinos c'est pas
juste suis plateau royal puis dans les
quartiers chics par toi mon gars tout le
monde le dit le mot clé gens se parlent
c'est un stage m'a gardé parce que toi
au vert en trouver un autre
et les inévitables mais les
propriétaires en profitent même si la
régie du logement avait dit à l'audience
il ya un gros problème de logement à
montréal puis c'est pas difficile de
comprendre que ça va être un des gangs
aux enjeux de la campagne
oui c'est pas que montréal la première
deuxième troisième couronne même à
québec et ailleurs ça se manifeste pas
seulement mon un christian du four
cette question est un peu classique en
fait pour les partis de gauche
ça a marché beaucoup pour manon massé
québec solidaire parce que c'est clair
que monsieur legault peut passer le test
en ce qui a trait aux prix des logements
montréal il est franchement déconnecté
et ça donne l'idée que peut-être que les
politiciens devraient une fois par année
en fait subir un petit un petit cours
sur le prix du billet de métro des pays
de l'est les livres de steak haché cela
dit pour le bien de mes tromperait
comprendre mais que monsieur legault en
fait sujet ce thème à ce point là le
prix des logements à montréal c'est plus
gênant en soi c'est paul prix du métro
mais parce qu'on comprendrait que le
premier ministre prenne pas un métro
donc à montréal on
dion le redis je pour adopter ce qu'on
dit mes deux collègues mais les prix des
loyers sont beaucoup plus élevés que ce
que pense monsieur le vaux bien sûr six
à huit étudiants aux cinq étudiants
trois étudiants un appartement
on parle de familles souvent des femmes
monoparentales qui cherchent un logement
puis on leur demande des 900 pour des
logements encore une fois des crépis
presque des taudis c'est ça la situation
maintenant à montréal
très bien mais trop chercher trouver sa
maîtrise des trois chambres à coucher
je mets au défi de trouver dans une
semaine il y avait but et c'est ça le
problème
bon et les solutions sont pas évident
non plus pour un gouvernement mais il ya
une question martin ont conclu la
subtile de sensibilité mais c'est ça
c'est mais en plus c'est que le gros de
cette crise du logement là elle va se
vivre durant l'été le 1er juillet lors
on va vivre personne à l'assemblée
nationale au mois de juillet alors c'est
comme si on est dans d'autres choses que
dans celles présentes
bon il explose hors du prix de
l'immobilier depuis qu externe province
exactement r dans les écoles c'est pas
tellement l'air les écoles et le
ministre de l'éducation qui était montré
dans cette même interpellation du 1er
mai est montré du doigt je veux entendre
quelques extraits et on revient pourquoi
lui vaut les critiques sont beaucoup
plus élevées des parrains du réseau
dessin ce qu il le met six rapports qui
convaincu que dans toute son équipe
c'est la meilleure personne pour le
faire au best un peu d'ancienneté comme
intel au début de la car j'ai eu
pleinement confiance au ministre de
l'éducation
c'est un enseignant est lui même qui
connaît bien les enjeux connaît bien les
défis les propos du premier ministre
confirme la grande patience
la très très grande patience légaux
préhensibles patience qu'il a envers le
ministre de l'éducation
il ya peu d'éléments nouveaux
aujourd'hui michel cymes et c'est de
cette histoire où le ministre avait
laissé entendre qu'il y avait eu l'aval
de la santé publique pour faire les
fameux tests dans les écoles dans les
classes du québec la santé publique a
dit non non non on n'a pas donné l'aval
on avait même des doutes sur certaines
procédures bref c'est cet imbroglio là
qu'il traîne il ya plus d'élément
nouveau mais on sent que c'est un
maillot maillon faible aux yeux de
l'opposition tout cas c'est actuellement
le maillon faible du gouvernement ça
c'est clair et c'est pas pour rien que
vous avez dit une autre vue de mener par
les prochaines oppositions c'est assez
exacte comme description de l'exercice
dans ces exercices en opposition envers
le maillon faible
ayant retrouvé un parce que pendant des
mois et des mois c'était difficile de
trouver qui on pourrait attaquer la caq
parce que les ministres aient le choix
entre un début de mandat soit ce avaient
l'air de bien performer mais là ils ont
des idées et la question de la
ventilation des écoles série la phrase
célèbre monsieur robert je sais les
tests sont parfaits n'y a pas de
problème on va tenir compte des
critiques qui nous aurons c'est l'autre
mais c'est des réponses comme ça qui
donne actuellement et on essaie de
renforcer son équipe autour de lui
cette réaction de choses mais il reste
un petit mot là-dessus kassian pauvre
monsieur robert je suis le seul à avoir
encore un peu de sympathie pour lui
parce que c'est lantenay pour
commentateurs aux analystes à tout le
monde le sait il serait plus au cabinet
bst a pu le mignan quelque part
aujourd'hui parce qu'au fond il était
désavoué ce cas c'était par monsieur
arodaky lui même perdu beaucoup des plus
longs qui n'étaient pas confrontés à un
foudre
de guerre mais plus sérieusement c'est
ça faire ressentir à quel point monsieur
legault a eu de la difficulté en fait à
laisser aller des ministres qu'il a
choisi au point de départ il est très
fidèle à son équipement chic à quel
point c'est une raison ou poche qu'on
n'est pas celle de aussi pour aller
jusqu'au lâcher quelques fois c'est un
véritable problème ma toile une
unanimité tout le monde d'après ce que
je comprends qu'il en est vraiment faut
se méfier de ce raid unité martin on a
on en a souvent par l'ensemble à ce
panel ce que ça a évolué dans votre
esprit
l'analyse sur le ministre auberges et
puis la ventilation c'est un des
exemples parce que d'autres dossiers la
ventilation c'est à peu près je pense le
seul dossier qui a traversé les trois
vague de cette pandémie l'os sans jamais
se régler complètement
et puis je parle pas des maternelles
quatre ans puis je parle pas non plus de
l'abolition des commissions scolaires
qui très difficile
monsieur legault paul choix de le
défendre aujourd'hui parce qu'il veut
pour faire un remaniement demain ou la
semaine prochaine le jour où il lâché
après le choix de faire un remaniement
mais a beaucoup de voix autour de deux
conseillers autour de monsieur legault
qui milite pour un remaniement
substantiel
après la pandémie donne un second
souffle à son gouvernement probablement
à l'automne et se serait pas étonnant
que monsieur roberge partech soient
invités gentiment je pense pas que
monsieur legault vol de larguer parce
qu'effectivement si un de ses amis ses
proches ses fidèles et je le dis souvent
que ceux qui font des grosses réformes
surtout dans des gros réseau un moment
donné il faut qu'ils partent s'ils
veulent sauver leur carrière mais
monsieur legault va vouloir finir
l'année électorale avec un peu plus
d'harmonie au sein de ce ministère la
avec les profs les enseignants mais
aussi avec les parents qui n'oubliait
pas sont des électeurs oui et quand les
négociations avec le réseau seront
terminés ça va aussi apaiser un peu les
choses faut quand même le dire un
contexte oui mais les parents quand même
sont pas content et ça et ces gens ils
vont cet aspect lors des négociations
mais quand les parents sont pas contents
seuls les gouvernements une fois son bon
référendum sur le mode de scrutin
on écoute madame lebel
c'est terminé y en a un rapport pandémie
présentement en troisième vague
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire dans la
relance économique dans la sécurité
centa alors c'est pas sonia lebel dans
son bureau qui dit oh mon école j'aime
trop la chose enfin ses portes en 2012
là ce sont non la pandémie a pas le
dollar est un déni à l'îlot la ministre
faisant reprendre la demande
ça nous déçoit ça déçoit tous ceux qui
ont porté leur confiance dans ce
processus
on croyait que le gouvernement de la caq
aurait honoré son engagement il n'en est
rien
bon il y en aura pas de référendum sur
le mode de scrutin lors de la prochaine
élection
martin s'est un peu écrit dans ciel là
c'est ici une série glee ou en tongs pas
bonnes notes chaise de toute façon il
n'y a pas de manifestations dans la rue
pour un référendum sur le mode de
scrutin à la prochaine élection
c'est vrai que la pandémie est là et que
eu beaucoup d'enjeux à régler cela dit
le gouvernement de la cac et celui qui
est allé le plus loin dans ce dossier là
en déposant un projet de loi ni les
libéraux et les péquistes qui ont
discuté où il ya eu des débats
épouvantables dans tous les caucus là
dessus parce que il faut pouvoir les
caucus sont moins moins friands de ce
type de promesses là il reste quand même
que le gouvernement a déposé un projet
de loi et à sa décharge je dirais que
sonia lebel et les sincères je pense
qu'elle est c'est celle qui est il plus
sincères au sein de ce gouvernement sur
ce dossier là et elle voulait vraiment
lemmings bon michel si vous n'êtes pas
étonné non plus n'ont écouté ce pas la
pandémie que les raisons du report du
scrutin et avec égal avec seize fois son
livre non plus c'est le fait que les
députés du parti ministériel ne veulent
pas en entendre parler 15 ont été élus
par une solution de la garder la
solution gagnante
ils sont pas pires locked le
gouvernement avait fait les mêmes
promesses sont pas mieux non plus mais
je le vrai problème de tout ça c'est que
les députés derrière bas qui sont fait
élire 10
on changera pas de système qui nous a
fait élire c'est juste pas vrai il ya
une révolte du caucus convient de une
dans d'autres dans d'autres partis donc
si jamais on se reporte pas la prochaine
fois en 22 donc s'il y avait un
référendum ce serait en 27 pour 1
filiation entre en mai l'or
christian s'est reportée aux calendes
grecques ouais avocat en politique
les projets comme les personnages
peuvent avoir plusieurs vies donc on ne
sait jamais mais c'est une réforme qui
est conditionnel defacto dont il faut
avoir un gros mot même thème pour la
mener à terme
je trouvais quand même la performance de
son label aujourd'hui assez réussis pas
c'est vrai qu'elle avait l'air d'y
croire le fan défendu loyalement et là
vraiment l'esprit d'équipé bien est ce
qu'il le fait rappelons quand même que
dans les prochains jours étant donné que
la grande majorité des élites
intellectuelles sont pour la réforme du
mode de scrutin pour des motifs
éminemment noble on va avoir des
articles prêtre est très prégnant qui
vont on dira ce sont les méchants
députés qui sont juste s'occuper de
leurs intérêts communs dit michel je
rappellerai que d'autres personnes dont
moi mais je suis pas le seul du tout je
peux refaire le débat mais avait quand
même un argumentaire sur le power
québécois au sein du canada sur le poids
de la majorité francophone au sein du
québec et sur le poids des régions donc
c'est pas vrai que d'un côté tu avais
les gens qui est un noble qui défendrait
la proportionnelle et les autres pour le
reste on sait jamais ça peut revenir si
ce n'est la belle devrait payer 1000 ce
qui sait peut-être kerviel va très bien
ok alors
roulement de tambour celle ci vous avez
annoncé votre successeur que l'on
connaît bien à l'émission
alec castonguay café qui nous a fait le
plaisir de venir nous dire bonjour
alec vous êtes là vous voyez je suis là
bonjour alors félicitations j'avais été
nommé le successeur de michel c'est aux
jets à cette émission important du midi
d'abord je donne la parole à michel c
sait on est content n'est ce pas si m
plus qu accepter quitté démission comme
ça c'est comme se faire échanger au
hockey tu veux pas te faire est chargé
par un choix de quatrième ronde
c'est un des meilleurs journalistes
politiques de cette génération sinon les
auditeurs super bon ben bravo et je
croise j'ajoute ma voix à celle de
michel c'est je crois que les blues
étant un très très très bon journaliste
politique vous nous l'avez prouvé vous
le prouver au panel dans les émissions
spéciales et vous allez avoir beaucoup
de plaisir
à midi un faux petit tour de table
martin vous avez appris la nouvelle donc
aujourd'hui sa réaction je suis
enchantée jeu après avoir contenu ma
peine de voir michel partir j'ai tout de
suite pensé à alec il le sait il peut
même le confirmer je lui ai fait part
de mon sentiment de joie oui de 20
joueurs justement j'ai fait part qu'il
devrait lever la main à quai ou ce
poste-là je le voyais là c'est le
premier j'avais bien c'est bien
christian petit monde ben moi qui ai pas
tellement vieux d'habitude je m'en veux
un peu parce qu'à l'âge qui leur allait
qu'avec l'expérience qu'il a c'est un
merveilleux défi qu'il a relevé j'ai
quand même assez émouvant le passage de
relais entre les générations qui
investissent le michel c'est d'une part
et avec donc bonne chance à lui d'abord
c'est vrai que martin a été la première
à me dit tu devrais lever la main je lui
dit voyons machine j'ai jamais fait ça
vont animer une émission de radio dans
ma vie et elle le dit bah pourquoi pas
quand même et c'est tout à fait un
hasard comme les proposer après alors
martine effectivement eu de la
clairvoyance pour lui donner ça ensuite
remplacé michel eeckhout je me sentais
tout petit dans mes souliers quand je
lui ai parlé ce matin en faisant ce qui
était quand même content que ce soit moi
puis le dia je suis très content que ce
soit toi je ne me pensais pas qu'il
allait me comparer avec un homme et
d'éviter par exemple j'avoue qu'il a je
n'aurais pas été jusque là mais je suis
effectivement honorée de cette
opportunité l'ofppt imedi info c'est une
émission que moi j'aime que j'écoute
taillé sur mesure sur la politique
l'information internationale des
affaires publiques
alors je pense beaucoup de plaisir
j'espère que les auditeurs on avoir
autant que moi à chaque midi
je suis sûr c'est un très bon choix
voire très bons coups de latte au canada
et on est très contents alec et michel
siffre damas vous disparaissez pas mais
non vous allez non mais je parle là même
après on va au panel ça va prendre
encore du temps avant que je puisse soit
plus capable
merci beaucoup merci à vous quatre bonne
soirée me roy
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit